car il ya combien de tomes je suis pas
prêt de 4 go et des lunettes teintées de
tenter depuis au moins 25 ans les quatre
corps exactement depuis février 76 savez
12 en tous sens et bien c'est donc parce
que vous êtes c'était en février savait
juste 12 ans
ce n'est pas mal non je n'ai pas mal
parce que je n'ai pas envie d'aller chez
le coiffeur tout le temps passait pas le
temps tel qu'on fait la paix comme tout
le monde apprécie quand c'est fait on
n'a pas besoin d'y penser toute la
journée 1
sinon comme je suis sùr idée
naturellement ça me faisait une
préoccupation quotidienne comme devant
voyager n'est pas le temps d'aller
jusqu'à faire douter vie que je n'ai pas
un don peuvent dans cette ville alors
pour moi c'est la solution idéale et
puis je pars du principe que le 18e
pendant un siècle
nous organisations alors si bien les
garder tous 15 à 20 ans pas plus que mes
cheveux blanchissent ça valait mieux en
mieux avec ce look c'est vrai que tu
dors quatre heures par nuit
ça c'est un peu exagéré mais je me
rattrape et voilà la journée mais je
peux très bien vivre en commun rattrape
en une du général j'essaye comme le dos
mais celle ci c'est vrai
quand même quand même c'est vrai que tu
travailles le matin qui dessinent de
5h30 ce matin comme hier soir j'ai eu le
malheur de regagner télévision a suivi
le film phare à se lever à 3 heures et
j'ai décidé de croiser de rentrer à la
maison ces retouches et une rapide très
grave tu vois je fais toujours du goût
j'ai treize enfants que tu pars demain
matin à milan avant noir au marron par
la vie quotidienne de carlingue a fait
c'est un peu compliqué parce que le
matin tu vas chez karl lagerfel l'après
midi tu vas chez chanel ouais mais tu
t'occupes compte 110 candidats lui reste
du temps et puis mes de ma collection
allemande dû magazine japonais
oui mais parfait à new york mais moi
j'aime ce côté être partout à la fois
des huit victimes qui n'existait pas
avant dans ce métier
les autres ne sont pas comme ça mais moi
ça me convient comme ça c'est ma nature
j'aime être partout à la fois c'est vrai
que tu décides 17 s'emmener le ballon
les jamais contesté rivel pense que je
dessine beaucoup plus parce que je crois
car ce que je fais des films toute façon
c'est pour la poubelle
ouais ça va dans la corbeille que ça
fait peut-être est-il maintenant je sais
pas mais pour moi tout s'est dessinée
c'est comme respirer je pense même pas
fait une chose automatique
moi je parle très vite je suis très vite
j'écris que ça vite pour moi c'est une
chance que j'aime faire un faux pas
c'est naturel commence par un travail à
plein temps de jeu tu as lu oui je
m'amuse je veux dire c'est que ce métier
m'amuse plus jolie qui a quasiment je ne
comprends pas mais c'est comme ça
justement tu étais né d'une famille
riche
la voix tu pouvais faire rien vraiment
établie mais quel ennui mais non mais tu
aurais pu courir les antiquaires est
occupé de temps j'en fais découvrir en
même temps mais n'arrivant plus à courir
les sans abri
moi j'arrive à combien tout ce que j'ai
envie de courir tout ce qui m'intéresse
la curiosité pour moi c'est le moteur
principal de la ville n'a aucun regret
d'avoir choisi une vie active plutôt
comme des lampes des débris semble pas
de regret donc l ennui donc j'ai banni
pour ça je suis ni paul champ de
bataille
alors dis donc tu viens de signer un
accord fin les produits lagerfeld vont
être tout une grande partie pour une
fabriqués par fleury crédit ont sous
l'égide de révision
beyond en plus zélés même groupe qui
pensait tous les meilleurs
la fête produit par une grosse rideau
qui s'est produit lappartient au même
groupe qui projette aussi de villon
tricard au mile end au centre
c'est pas gênant pour chanel femme
je ne pense pas la question je suis
assez comme ça là ils ont apparemment il
ya de place pour tout le monde
différents devis non au contraire je
reviens toujours à la même idée j'aime
l'ubiquité d'un créatif d'être moi même
et d'être quelqu'un d'autre en eau
froide à quillan
finalement tu es arrivé à quelque chose
d'assez assez rare c'est à dire que
avant tu as été un grand freeland
pendant longtemps maintenant que les
choses à toi mais tu arrive quand même à
imposer sa création à des sociétés qui
assurent la gestion pour toi ça s'est
passé
comme ça marche comme également
personnes sont là donc il n'ya pas de
malheureux en espoirs et
comme ça que je vois les affaires moi je
n'ai pas envie d'être le geste ulien
d'une que la faire tous les jours au
même endroit c'est pas ma mentalité
c'est pas ma nature
moi j'aime bouger les jeux ne vaut pas
un clou enfermés dans notre seul endroit
l'assemblée moi je ne suis pas
fonctionnaire rien contre les
fonctionnaires mais j'ai pas fonctionné
comment tu les considère alors qu'à
rennes c'est quoi c'est on s'est amusé
ce soit chez toi oui chanel c'est quoi
ta maîtresse
c'est plutôt un rôle que je joue comme
un acteur jouerait un rôle
par exemple fendi en italie j'ai ma
version italienne de moi même parce que
je me dis double ya plus
cette prétendue dépasser 5 c'est au tour
d'une forte personnalité mais qui ça
c'est les 5 seraient généralisées comme
ça avec leurs deux familles
mantha vert de la plus grosse affaire de
fourrure lormand domaine
[Applaudissements]
son vrai potentiel créatif énorme elle
n'a pas l'exprimer
non moi je ne sors ça de leur tête même
sans les concrétiser j'utilise la
créativité dans le sang c'est ça qui
trouve amusant d'amos très bientôt
mettre sur papier sont en vérité que les
autres alors dans la tête mais qui ne
peut pas exprimer mais je vais prendre à
la serveuse quelqu'un il l'exprimé pour
lui préparer un peu diabolique peur à
l'ehpad du diabolique puisque ce n'est
pas fait
il est mort
des égéries ceux qui adorent mais dans
une
tout sort pas d'une faute à l algérie c
y va tous aussi c'était beau bassin
plein de filles pour chanel c'est
surtout inès et j'étais très important
parce que je trouvais ça va être surtout
moi j'ai pas cette excuse moi tu fait
pour une femme par une femme mal il faut
que je puisse identifier tard avec une
femme précise sinon je ne dirai un mot
les fonctionnaires c'est pas moi mais ça
m'amuse je prendrai des éléments d'un
style données et d'adapter sa une fille
très belle moderne jeunes d'aujourd'hui
et je trouve qu'elle est là qu au
ministère le chesnay après les marchés
qu'apparemment les messages de la cia
traits du contre
et les filles qu'on voit 1,6 à notre
place depuis le début d'interview
séquelles fendi ou c est pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux